to translate visually to actually be in
Africa I think we need independence of
thought and I think Afghan countries
need to assert themselves but we did a
set of sovereignty I think we need to
recognize the fact that like any other
developed country it is it is an IHS to
protect our you shouldn't be scared to
take big decisions you shouldn't be
scared of words like protectionism we
shouldn't be scared of we should be
scared to embark on initiatives enable
us to grow our economies to help a lot
and entrepreneurs and we should
recognize the fact that in the
development curve of things is very
different for anything that our
countries are and if today they still
protections in industries in favor of
the citizens I think we shouldn't have
to do that as well my fear is that this
could be one initiative that could
dramatically change the state of
entrepreneurship on our continent and
entrepreneurship is to a large extent
but I think were assisted I